[Music]
hey guys did you know that Jane uses in
podcast format I'm sure you know by now
cuz all these videos have been
mentioning it but click on the links in
the description and you can listen in
and don't forget to rate at 5 stars
listen to it while you're [ __ ] that's
a whale [ __ ] that's a welcome you're
welcome welcome in I D the drunk news
submitted by sheep squad sheep noise
what is that the gang of sheep let's go
or sheep
oh that's monkey fools scream a weird
words yeah like there's like a whole
video go yeah they do you scream uber
has applied for a patent to use AI to
help identify drunk passengers oh [ __ ] I
think anybody can identify it pretty
easy you wanna do you wanna go party
with an M yeah they just breathalyzer
Oh that'd be perfect mmm well this is
more like so uber drivers can decide
whether or not they want to pick up that
pass all before they drunk text a drunk
call to drunk things so this AI
apparently will determine how drunk the
potential passenger is by accurately
measuring how they're typing how they're
even holding their phone like the angle
Oh
the passengers location like if they
would if you just woke up there's no
difference between someone that just
woke up in a truck if any of you have
received any of my texts it always sound
like I'm drunk
I have so many [ __ ] typos maybe they
memorize how you do it on a regular
whatever to the breathalyzer thing well
you couldn't go on your phone yeah you
can blow on your phone and it'll tell
you how drunk you can't you answer blow
on it through yeah yeah but you need the
actual I think you know what it's oh my
god I think she backpack know what's
holding you back
sure you're not that smart anyways
continue no there I did see like an
application on application but like it's
um are you - yeah there's you were
trawling us but we really think you're
that dumb though I got you guys wait
hold on a second do you think I'm stupid
because I believed her to be the dumbass
mom just shows you how much you trust
Gio's word people right next to me with
the Fez case that it will take ten
credit cards yeah no this is just a
seven plus oh yeah you do have the home
yeah oh my god anyway so a lot of
critics are saying that this is they're
taking it too far to try to
differentiate like who's drunk who's not
because then they can easily be
discriminating the drivers killer gays
alcohol is against drunk people and then
what are the drunk people gonna do now
to get home like they don't [ __ ]
control their goddamn alcohol or they
just in a car drive home
like some response I can't get it over
I'm drunk might as well drive that's
true yeah that that was a selling point
like don't drink and drive get an uber
and into Ober drivers like I'm tired of
these drunk [ __ ] puking in my car
forgetting to pay [ __ ] doing all kind
of can't forget to pay at the net I
think you just walk out I legit just one
I take uber and lift so much I have so
many [ __ ] weird like incidences
stories I just want to recreate them all
cuz it's just it's just a gamble dude
yeah you just never know sometimes I'd
like that I will say this there would be
rule that if you get [ __ ] uber
premier though or a lift the the upper
upper [ __ ] they're all fantastic oh yeah
they're [ __ ] amazing dude they give
you gamba give me the waters they even
gots the wi-fi's and some of them dude
it's crazy this guy was like would you
like to connect to Wi-Fi I was like okay
me go for the with the wee-fee
you get the [ __ ] out of here with the
wee-fee I took over in Texas one time it
was the coolest over on earth it was his
Mexican dude I don't know if he knew
English that well but he had a hooked up
a scar there was a karaoke thing he was
like okay and I was like man yo get off
the Red Nosed Reindeer with them and
[ __ ] oh you're by yourself yells by
myself but it was okay no but then he
had like a basket full of [ __ ] he
just had a lot of candy oh yeah bubble
pops like he's like people get nervous
and then like they pop those little
little things that you could pop like
nervous all the other things he had
[ __ ] tissue man he had everything
dude everything I become rich on the
uber premiere from here oh yeah dry for
you just to let you know I was the guy
that said that I found a time machine I
would go back in time and just buy a lot
of nice and gas instead of buying a lot
of ticket or [ __ ] like that super powers
to do swap wasn't here that do big
sandwich stupid cream
I feel better it's all that it is Double
Stuf Oreos actually now we're done yeah
but uh yeah
uber uber identifying drunk people you
know ubers invented by old man really
it sounds like an old man's name I saw a
commercial and it was like you know the
guy comes out and there's a UH it's like
CEO and I'm like dad I feel old CEO does
that that means you he invent or he got
hired presidents usually the ones that
kind of own it
there's someone all in there
I thought you think it's stupid sandwich
honors now you and I are the cream I saw
the commercial I was like I thought app
companies were all young people's and I
was like this guy has too many white
hairs to qualify all right it's up to us
don't [ __ ] it up you know what I mean
there's a reason why they come watches
every game watches because they love the
intelligent conversation the [ __ ]
news thank God the dated news that they
come here for the stupid sandwich is
pretty big because Julia fools are pizza
at the wrong way other people do it but
you're associated with people like that
and that's like saying you have friends
that are rapists but she saw people I
don't rest fun you guys associated her
with them you saw somebody doing
arrested [ __ ] wild you can't win the
person took a whole pizza that was a
circle and roll it
don't bomb wouldn't imagine putting a
long hot dog inside just playing it safe
right now he's not saying I was just
thinking about what we should do about
all the drunk people that can't take
uber is now because of this shit's not
they're not picking them up some keys
give the keys to cars not thinking about
these drugs
chuckles drop shuttles so put a whole
bunch of rowdy [ __ ] drunk people to
the do you know how much fun shake could
happen at the party would yeah it's a
party bus
did I hate when people get drunk and
they don't understand proximity oh yes
and I started talking drunk pizza
completely dumb ass PJs dime first of
all there was a dumb ass salad I was a
dumbass Pizza big circle I like
proximity like this
black ass shoulder and looked at Jolie
no wonder she wears the circles like
those shirts of them all we all all we
legit need all we need now see my
shoulder do something like this Ryan
just needs to come out and trip over and
kill these lights on he's a command to
destroy all these life if not the
cameras over the one day she don't wear
that shirt at the halls blend it in like
my shadow dude [ __ ] dude and I was like
I wanted to do the act out for the jump
out and we bow like that I knocked out
my own [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how dare you wear a shirt that blends in
with your hair that's a hazard damn it's
like a [ __ ] shadow and I just see
face [ __ ] man
I only had a few minutes to go and I
[ __ ] up this is stupid
yep you are Jake a pizza what kind of
flavor
stupid stupid on alright but anyway yeah
so drunk drunk but alright yeah so what
I was thinking of is we should have a
drunk shuttle that the city pays for and
they just kind of pick up junk people
and take them kind of like the airport
where they when you parked in and they
pick you up yeah I will say this though
if you are drinking and driving now you
have no excuse cuz there's so many like
apps there's like Waze has one no to
like wait people yeah that ways has like
a uber type app - yeah yeah so there's
like so many different options and you
can even just go oh let's go and call a
taxi - they're still around oh let's go
have a DeeDee all you got to do is go to
a k-town restaurant and all that issue a
couple give you a card and the Korean
that's the original uber there's an old
man with a business card and they drive
really fast really fast dude
and so that one dangerous there like a
personal you want you to throw it's so
funny they don't speak any English at
all and then we were trying to get to a
street called Mariposa I was like
Mariposa oh yeah
Mariposa or Maddie pooja yeah okay